are those are those just
sort of like click-baity headlines where
they talk about making
uh little black holes with lhc or or
specif like purposely creating
black holes well uh mostly yes you're
seeing click-baity things
so so the theory does predict that um
it you know it's possible that it could
create
really many black holes um but the idea
that it would create a black hole that
would destroy the universe is just
complete fiction
and um you know it was
astonishingly it was mostly promoted
by this you know ridiculous
high school science teacher in hawaii
and you know but because
it had such you know sensationalistic
aspects it was picked up by the press
everywhere and this guy really knew
nothing i mean
in fact as they you know they said if he
read the next lines
in the in a paper you know any technical
papers that the same theory that
predicted
that you could possibly create a mini
black hole also predicted it would
evaporate almost immediately
so um and uh you know but unfortunately
it did get the attention of the press
and i remember
i was over there at cern right before
the first big turn on and
you know there were big headlines and so
it did force
the uh administration to
you know basically take a couple of
physicists and say
okay we you really need to do another
study just definitively show that this
is not a problem
um which they did but and you know the
other argument
is that in the cosmos there are
collisions happening at
far far greater energies than we can
ever create
here and the universe is here
so you know if if this was really a
problem
um if if you know these high energy
collisions could create these things
that would destroy our universe
they you know most likely would have
already happened
and we wouldn't be here to worry about
it
how are we ever going to figure out what
dark matter is
well um i mean it's basically just
blackness nothingness right that's how
we can perceive it
yeah yes well but we do it does have
effects on mass
and things like that so you know we do
um
dark means that it's not visible
electromagnetically
it doesn't mean that it's not uh all
that it doesn't interact in other ways
we know it
interacts gravitationally so we can we
can detect things that don't emit light
because of the other properties i mean
there are other particles that
you know don't emit light that don't
have a charge or something like that
um so that we can detect them because of
their interactions through these other
forces
okay does that make sense so so you know
you're saying how do we detect something
because we can't see it but seeing is
only one way of
detecting things uh we can detect things
which is how we know that it exists
which is how we know that dark matter
exists because of
gravity so it affects other things right
so
so um you know if you saw if you saw
something
rotating you know you know it's so you
saw something that you can see
and it's going around in a circle
uh you know we to keep something going
in a circle
we know is gravity needs to keep
something going in a circle
there needs to be a force okay i mean
even at the simplest level of newton's
laws we know that
things you know if they don't go in a
straight line
there's got to be a force that's holding
it in so the reason things
you know any object any object with mass
moves around
something is because something is
holding it in
now that something could be um
electricity and magnetism and so if
you know if you have a positive or say
you have a positive thing
at the center and an electron around it
like
you know there's a primitive idea of an
atom right an electron okay
it's the electromagnetic force that's
holding it together right the
attraction between positive and negative
charges um
you have the earth going around the sun
it's because the sun
has a huge mass and the earth is and the
other has also has mass and it moves
around it
but you know suppose um
you know uh it's possible that
um you you don't see something so
suppose there's something out there and
it doesn't emit light
like the sun but we see an object we see
a planet moving around
something okay or even what we see is
sometimes
whole you know a whole galaxy is moving
around something
we know something is there something is
there we can't see it
because it's not emitting light like the
sun but we know something is there
and so that's how you know if you study
the motion
of these things you know what the speed
is what the distance is what the
curvature is again the curvature is
really important how
we can tell what the strength of this
thing is and what we can tell properties
about it
even though we can't see it
conventionally with light
have you ever seen the movie
interstellar yes
what did you think about what did you
think about it did you like it um
uh personally i liked the human story
the most
um but i think you know i mean um
[Music]
what i read is actually one of the
originators of it and you know so
i mean you know kip is a you know
very very respected physicist
and you know they i think made it as
realistic as you know as possible and in
a speculative way
so it had uh it had uh
you know it was very very legitimately
done they i i know that the
graphics people actually really worked
with i think with scientists and even
i i think may have even written a couple
of scientific papers on how do you
visualize certain of those
aspects of it and things like that so so
it really
dealt with that as well um again you
know i mean it is
for me an interesting thing is i i
primarily i
i consider myself a filmmaker at this
point and so
i when i look at a film i'm looking um
at how they are dealing with that aspect
of it and i thought there were some very
interesting things there i thought you
know with the
you know i i actually thought the way
that they handled
some of the things nearer the end with
the
the different dimensions with the
daughter and the father was was
very very interesting actually the
hardest part for me to
conceptualize was the way that
time changed how he got farther away
from
the earth and time went slower for him
than it went on earth because at the
when he came back at the end his
daughter was like 100 years old and he
was still like the same age
right yeah and that's a function of
relativity you know it's part of
einstein's theory in in in terms of how
the time and space dimensions get uh
altered and um
again in a similar way to um
i mean you know somewhat parallel to
what i was talking about the way
you know things shift when they're
moving in color
right that you shift frequencies there's
a you know
a certain sense too what you can imagine
that you know it's
time also can be changing you know that
uh when you're moving when you're under
under the effect of a field of a strong
gravitational field or something like
that so
so i don't know if that helps at all but
think in terms of
the way we know that sound or colors can
shift when you're moving
well um time as can as well actually
i think the next thing that we're going
to discover at cern is time machines
i think that would be pretty cool